hi guys in this video we want to talk
about how to increase muscle mass with
exercise and this is a principle that
you need to follow it's definitely not
low weight high reps it's not taking
your bike out it is basically higher
amounts of weights lower reps lots of
recovery okay so you want to work up
this all the time higher personal
trainer that help you with the technique
but you want to put as much weight as
you can so you can barely do like 5 reps
that's how you create this expansion of
your muscles is called myofibrillar
hypertrophy where you're taking the
muscle cell and you're traumatizing it
for the body to recover and expand and
get bigger and you're not going to
actually do this on the treadmill it's
going to have to be actual weights the
key is the recovery though to get eight
to nine hours of sleep
why because first of all the intensity
that's going to be created from this is
going to stimulate growth hormone growth
hormone is going to help you with muscle
mass growth hormone is also triggered by
sleep beings so we want a combination of
great recovery high amount of weight
slower reps and then you want to do
what's called compound resistance
exercise where you're working multiple
joints at one time like the squat the
deadlift overhead Porsche and powerclean
these are exercises that you can do that
are compound and they can create some
serious high intensity but of course we
want to keep it low reps something like
five five maybe to five to seven that
would be enough and you want to
gradually work up to this but this
principle will definitely help you if
you want to start getting bigger thanks
for watching you know just wanted to
take a moment out to thank you for your
amazing feedback that you guys are
giving me it's just mind-blowing
the successes the wins I created a link
down below so you can actually type out
your full success story and if you have
a before and after with weight loss that
would be awesome if you don't have a
success with weight but other things
just put an image of yourself and your
personal success story and I would love
to read it and also share it with
so I want to just thank you in advance
for doing that but there's a link down
below fill it out I can't wait to read
it